Film Courage: There are critics who argue
that popular culture is “dumbing down.”
Would you say this is true, reflected in the
film and television of today?
Karl Iglesias: I think I’m on the fence
about that.
It really depends on what movies and TV are
very popular.
I mean when I see movies like TRANSFORMERS,
like the glut of superhero movies, I go Hmmm?
It’s kind of sad that audiences are responding
to that and making the movie successful, which
just brings about more movies.
Studios are all about making movies that make
money, so I understand why they keep making
them.
But for me I’m kind of getting a little
tired of that.
That being said, it doesn’t mean that there
is not good storytelling out there.
I think it’s great that there are more avenues
for stories, Netflix, Amazon, online and all
this stuff is opening up….The Golden Age
of Television…I think there is much great
TV being written now than there was before
so all that gives me confidence about the
state of storytelling today.
I’m kind of happy about that.
I think if you look at the history of entertainment
there has always been both sides, so I’m
kind of in the middle.
I wouldn’t say “Yes, we’re dumbing down”
or “We’re getting better.”
It’s both, as it’s has always been.
Film Courage: Do you think we are making
more complex characters these days?
Karl Iglesias: I think so.
One of the things about storytelling is that
we’re conditioned to respond to new things,
to pay attention to new things.
That is why we like high-concept, part of
it is what I call the uniquely familiar.
You have to come up with something unique
that we’ve never seen before that is also
familiar.
You know this joke about the executive saying
“Yeah, just give me the same thing only
different.”
Right?
You’ve probably heard this before.
That is what it means.
We want to see stories that are different
but familiar, the same thing but in a different
way, a different angle.
The thing with characters is that we see more
and more characters in more and more stories,
we have to come up with something that is
new.
We have to come up with new characters or
new traits or new goals.
It’s getting harder and harder and harder
so because of that I think they’re becoming
more complex.
Because of all the entertainment that has
been done, good storytellers are aware of
that.
To answer your previous question about beginning
writers, the reason we see a lot of material
we’ve seen before, kind of like cliché
stuff is because they are not aware of what
has been done before.
So part of your education as a writer is really
to know what has been done before.
You really have to be very knowledgable about
this.
You have to be a geek about this, knowing
all the movies that have been done before,
knowing all the TV that has been done before,
all the comic books that have been done before
so you know that when you create something
you try to avoid that and come up with something
unique.
There is nothing new under the sun.
Everything has been done before but I am always
amazed and excited when there is a new concept.
I’m like “Oh, my God!
That’s is brilliant.”
Because it is familiar but it’s unique.
It is all about creativity and originality
and that is really a big part of being an
artist.
You have to be original.
That is why we respond to it.
Film Courage: [Imitating an executive at a
pitch meeting] “Love it!
But it’s too close to King Lear.
Sorry…”
Karl Iglesias: [Laughs] Right….but look
what they’ve done with King Lear!
You can modernize it and have a unique angle
on it.
Question For Viewers: Are you watching more
television shows than movies?